[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in eigenem Ennstal
mein Name ist Udo Koller ich bin der
staffelkommandant und der
kasernenkommandant von dieser Kaserne
und Pilot auf alle drei und der ab 169
hinter uns steht der neueste
Hubschrauber und modernste Hubschrauber
des österreichischen Bundesheers die
aw169 von der Firma Leonardo die habe
169 ist ein Hubschrauber der vielseitig
einsetzbar ist unsere gesamte
Einsatzspektrum für die militärischen
Zwecke und auch für assistenzeinsätze
abdecken kann
ja 169 wie man sieht bietet das
modernste an Features und
Sicherheitsaspekten vorne haben wir zum
Beispiel in der Nase oder unter der Nase
den cable Cutter der Zweck dieses Kabel
in ein Seil fliegen sollte natürlich
wissen die Piloten wo die Seile sind
aber falls einen Seil fliegen sollte
wird das Seil hier eingefangen und hier
abgeschnitten das gleiche ist natürlich
auch für den Bereich über der Nase dann
wird das Seil abgeleitet nach oben und
dann sieht man dann oben über der Kabine
den zweiten cable Carter wo auch von
oben das Kabel abgeschnitten wird in den
dementsprechenden Fall hier ist dann im
weiteren Folge in der Nase dann das
Wetterradar drinnen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ist bei schlechten
Wetterverhältnissen suchen
rettungsflügen die wir durchführen
müssen im Hochgebirge und hier auch
dementsprechend die Anzeigen haben
dahinter befinden sich verschiedenste
Geräte und elektronisches Gerät und dann
für die Windschutzscheibe für die klare
Sicht des Piloten der Scheibenwischer
der ganz massiv ausgeprägt ist und auch
die Eigenheit hat über diese Wölbung
eigentlich nicht hat drüberw
ischt aber sonst ist er grundsätzlich
gleich zu bedienen wie der
Scheibenwischer bei einem normalen KFZ
hier dieses Gerät habt ihr vielleicht
schon irgendwo gesehen bei einer anderen
Hubschrauber das ist ganz einfach nur
der staudruckmessung hier ist vorne ein
Loch und der Druck der Luftdruck wird
hier gemessen und somit wird den Pilot
der Geschwindigkeit der Hubschraubers
angezeigt
diese staurauer ist beheizbar damit es
winterlichen Flugbedingungen und tiefen
Temperaturen nicht vereist und das
vordere Loch nicht geschlossen wird
damit die Anzeige immer gegeben ist ja
dann gehen wir weiter zurück hier kommen
wir auch schon zur ersten Tür rechts
vorne in dem Bereich sitzt der
verantwortliche Pilot und zu diesem
Bereich wenn man dann später noch
genaueres sehen
würde zweiter nach hinten gehen wir
haben hier Beleuchtungen hier eine
Außentemperaturfühler ein
außentemperaturmessung und auch für
militärische spezielle
Beleuchtungsvarianten die der
Hubschrauber bietet so nach der
Beleuchtung sehen wir dann in dem
Bereich die Rettungswinde das ist das
Herzstück für einen Rettungshubschrauber
im alpinen Gelände zur Bergung von
Verletzten oder Personen oder auch von
anderen Piloten die abgestürzt oder
ausgestiegen sind oder mit dem
fördersitz ausgestiegen sind ist es
erforderlich mit dem Hubschrauber den
Notarzt zu den Verletzten zu bringen und
den Flugretter mit dem Notarzt hinunter
zu lassen zu den verletzten der dann
versorgt wird und im Endeffekt mit der
rettungsschwindel geborgen und wieder
eingeladen wird die Rettungswinde
funktioniert sehr schnell und hat eine
Seil Länge von 88 Metern das ist für uns
ein sehr großer Vorteil ist und ein
richtiger Quantensprung im Sinne der
Flugrettung ist weil auf alle drei
hatten wir doch ein viel kürzeres Seil
so dann schauen wir mal in den
Hubschrauber hinein
aber die hintere
Türe öffnen jetzt haben wir im
Kabinenraum der Kabinenraum bietet Platz
für bis zu zehn Personen zurzeit haben
wir eine Bestuhlung für sechs Personen
nach vorwärtsgerichtet man kann die
Bestuhlung je nachdem wie man sie
braucht einstellen die Sitze nach vorne
nach hinten gedreht man kann auch
Rettungs tragen in den Hubschrauber
einbauen verschiedenste Gerätschaften
zur Bedienung des wärmebildgerätes
operierter stations im Heck das heißt
das ist ganz ganz mannigfaltig hier in
diesem Bereich einsetzbar
auf dem Sitz
befindet sich im Flug normalerweise der
bohrtechniker der bohrtechniker hat
viele Aufgaben er hat den Hubschrauber
vor dem Flug anzuschauen und
dementsprechend technisch klar zu
schreiben und auch im Flug die
Triebwerks und anderen
Überwachungsinstrumente dementsprechend
zu beachten und auch irgendwelche
Ungereimtheiten sofort den Piloten zu
melden falls die Piloten das nicht
vorher schon sehen
der bohrtechniker hat die Aufgabe bei
einem Rettungseinsatz die Rettungswinde
zu bedienen und zur Bedienung dieser
Rettungswinde oder hier ein spezielles
Gerät und mit dem Gerät kann er mit der
Rettungswinde das Seil ein- und
ausfahren und dann kommen wir jetzt zu
einem ganz speziellen Punkt diese
Hubschraubers nämlich diese Hubschrauber
hat die Möglichkeit einer automatischen
schwebekontrolle das heißt der Pilot
kann vorne auf einen Knopf drücken und
der Hubschrauber bleibt im schwefelflug
und wenn es zu einer Bergung kommt und
der Bordtechniker den verletzten am
Boden sieht und der Pilot vielleicht
nicht die Möglichkeit hatte verletzten
so genau zu sehen dann hat der belohnt
die Möglichkeit den Bordtechniker den
Hubschrauber zu übergeben und der
Techniker kann den Hubschrauber dann mit
diesem Gerät und diesem
Steuerungsgerät dann den Hubschrauber
nach vorne nach hinten nach links und
nach rechts steuern damit das
Seil der rettungsschwindel genau zum
Verletzten hinkommt und der Flugretter
bzw Notarzt dort abgesetzt wird bzw auch
der verletzt angeboren wird das ganze
kann auch natürlich in der Nacht
passieren das heißt der Techniker hat
auch in der Nacht die Möglichkeit die
Rettungswinde zu bedienen damit er aber
dann unten auch etwas sieht kann er mit
diesem Knopf
den Scheinwerfer des Hubschraubers von
der rechten Seite bedienen und kann sich
auch den Scheinwerfer dorthin Steuern wo
er das Licht braucht und das ist schon
eine Besonderheit dieses Hubschraubers
und eine absolute Neuigkeit
das gelbe Gerät ist der bohrtechniker da
hinten hat ist ein Funkgerät damit er
natürlich Verbindung auch nach unten hat
zu den Flugretter und zu den Notarzt und
er kann das Funkgerät auch rausnehmen
falls ihr aber einen zwischeneinander
Platz aussteigen muss
gut das waren einmal die Aufgaben und
der Sitz des bautechnikers dann schauen
wir weiter bei unseren Rundgang
runterkopf mit den roter Blättern der
roter Kopf ist wartungsfrei der roter
dreht sich mit 338 Umdrehungen in der
Minute darunter unter der kauling
befindet sich das
haupt-200 PS und es dreht bis zu 50.000
Umdrehungen in der Minute die
Antriebswelle geht dann in den und das
hauptprotokgetriebe und das
hauptroutergetriebe und das setzt dann
diese Umdrehungen für die jeweilige
Umdrehung für den Hauptort der 338 und
für die Helikopter am Heck des
Triebwerkes
dann gehen wir weiter nach hinten das
sehen wir das Abgasrohr das Abgasrohr
kann man sehen dass das auch schon ein
ganz spezielles Material ist sowie das
ganze der ganze Bereich in dem des
Triebwerkes ist aus Titan nämlich aus
dem Zweck das im Falle eines Brandes der
Brand sich nicht so schnell auf den
restlichen Hubschrauber ausbreiten kann
und der Hubschrauber noch genügend Zeit
hat zu landen
so und jetzt können wir im Bereich des
Heckauslegers der Heckausleger hat die
Aufgabe auch unter anderem die heckrotte
Antriebswelle zu tragen und im Endeffekt
die Übertragung für den heckrotter
sicher zu stellen warum brauche ich
überhaupt ein heckrotter beim
Hubschrauber der Hubschrauber
dreht wie wir alle wissen der
Hauptrouter in eine bestimmte Richtungen
im Falle der August 9 dreht der linke
Seite das heißt Drehmoment würde auf den
Routen auf den Hubschrauber wie erwirkt
auf die linke Seite nach hinten
ausweichen wollen damit der Heck
Ausleger und der ganze Hubschrauber sich
nicht gegen die Drehrichtung des
hauptdroht das dreht haben wir da hinten
den heckrotter der quasi die Luft auf
die andere Seite hinüber drückt so dass
sich der Hubschrauber stabil bewegt
obwohl der hauptrot dass ich dreht und
wie einen gewaltigen Drehmoment auf den
Hubschrauber haben
und der Heckrotor braucht natürlich auch
dementsprechend Leistungen den
heckrotter soll man entlasten soweit es
nur geht weil jede leistungsersparnis
die wir im heckrotter haben haben wir
Leistungsgewinn am hauptruter wir können
mehr heben und in größeren Höhen
schweben die Besonderheit dieses
Heckauslegers liegt darin dass er hier
eine Rundung hat und wir werden das dann
auf der anderen Seite dann entdecken
dass der auf der anderen Seite dann
eigentlich ganz anders ausschaut
jedenfalls hier haben wir eine Rundung
im Schwebeflug hat der Hubschrauber
einen Download
der hier in dem Bereich wo wir stehen
herrscht von ca 120 km/h und diese 120
km/h nutzen wir aus um den heckrotter zu
helfen wie machen wir das jetzt
okay lassen das heißt durch diese
Rundung wird aerodynamisch der Luftstrom
beschleunigt und somit haben wir nach
dieser Richtung eine Sogwirkung das
heißt der hilft uns beim
drehmomentenausgleich und vermindert
somit die Erfordernis von mehr
Kraftanstrengungen
ein Gewinn für den drehmomentenausgleich
dann haben wir nur auf dieser Seite
unterhalb dieser weißen Antenne ein
Blech
dieses Blech leitet den Luftstrom der
beim von oben kommt
vom down wash wird das der Luftstrom
umgeleitet und wird auf diese Seite
geblasen
und dann haben wir wieder den gleichen
Effekt aufgrund des komprimierten
Blasens der Luft auf diese Seite wird
der Hubschrauber wiederum auf diese
Seite gedrückt das heißt hier haben wir
einen Sog und hier haben wir einen
dementsprechenden Druck das heißt der
drehmomentenausgleich wird unterstützt
und der heckrotte wird entlastet das ist
ganz so spezielle Funktion auch an
diesen Hubschrauber gibt es natürlich
auch bei anderen Hubschraubern aber das
ist unsere Hubschrauber hat das auch ja
dann gehen wir weiter zurück
kommen wir zur
stabilisierungs-horizontalen die hilft
uns im Vorwärtsflug dass der
Hubschrauber die dementsprechende Lage
beim vorwärts Flughafen
zu hoch ist das heißt dass der
Hubschrauber immer im Reiseflug gerade
ist
und es nicht beweglich das ist fix
eingestellt und er hat dynamisch
ausgerechnet
in dem Bereich
Meter Durchmesser ja den Zweck des
selbst
gehen auf diese Seite haben wir
die gleiche horizontale
stabilisierungsflosse und dann können
wir schon zu dem Bereich den ihr vorher
erwähnt habe diese Abrisskante die den
Luftstrom vom Downwash hier quasi mit
Verwirbelungen zerstört und auf diese
Seite keine Sogwirkung hat und im
Endeffekt dann der drehmomentenausgleich
sowie vorher beschrieben habe genau in
diese Richtung wo wir den
drehmomentenausgleich hin haben wollen
hinzieht
ja dann haben wir wieder Antenne auf
dieser Seite da die Bezeichnung des
Hubschraubers
das fünf bedeutet dass der Hubschrauber
in der 5 tonnenklasse ist und die
anderen Bezeichnungen wurden für diesen
Hubschrauber festgelegt haben wir wieder
das Abgasrohr
und unter dem Abgasrohr haben wir jetzt
ein ganz spezielles Gepäckabteil da
können wir mal reinschauen
das ist natürlich im Flugbetrieb
geschlossen also diese
diese honiggeräte und Batterien die man
hier sieht sondern natürlich im
Flugbetrieb nicht so offen das sind
verschlossen die sind jetzt nur zur
Wartungszwecken geöffnet man kann da bis
zu 250 Kilo in dieses Gepäcks
und dann schauen wir weiter die
Besonderheit von dieser Seite zur
anderen was man nur beachten kann jetzt
das ist dieses Ding hier und das ist die
Möglichkeit zu bedanken
der Hubschrauber fliegt mit Kerosin wie
die meisten anderen Luftfahrzeuge auch
und der Tank bildet ein Fassungsvermögen
von 1100 Litern und mit diesen 1100
Litern fliegt man je nach Flughöhe je
nach Beladung je nach Geschwindigkeit
zwischen zwei Stunden 30 und 4 Stunden
30 ist von den jeweiligen Faktoren die
vorher erwähntabhängigstufe
wiederum die Türe für den Eingang zum
Kabinenraum und dann haben wir noch was
spezielles auf dieser Seite das ist
dieses Gerät das ist ein Messgerät das
den Piloten anzeigt welche Luftfeuchte
und welche Temperatur im Außenbereich
herrscht so dass der Pilot weiß ob er
jetzt in einem Gebiet fliegt wo die
Möglichkeit einer Vereisung besteht das
heißt die Vereisung ist für den
Hubschrauber ein gewisses
Gefahrenpotenzial weil die Hauptort der
Blätter vereisen können dadurch wird die
Aerodynamik verändert und der Auftrieb
des Hubschraubers gestört und der
Hubschrauber kann auch als ganzer mit
Eis überzogen werden und würde dann
dementsprechend schwer werden und nicht
mehr zu fliegen sein das heißt es ist
ganz wichtiger Punkt dass der Pilot eine
Information hat ob er sich in schwerer
aufweisungsbedingungen befindet oder
nicht
vor im Endeffekt haben wir an diesem
Bereich genau das gleiche wie auf der
anderen Seite der staurer und den
Scheibenwischer und somit werden wir am
Ende bei unseren Rundgang und wie vorher
schon versprochen habe wenn man einen
Blick werfen
so jetzt befinden wir uns in cockpit von
der 169 ist unterscheidet sich natürlich
wesentlich zu den anderen Hubschraubern
die wir früher hatten die sehr sehr
viele analoge Anzeigegeräte hatten da
haben wir jetzt die im Endeffekt nur
mehr Bildschirme wir haben zwei primere
flight Displays wie sie genannt werden
und ein Multifunktionsdisplay in der
Mitte an dem primäre flight Displays
habe ich alle notwendigen Informationen
die ich für den Flug und für die Avionik
brauche für das Fliegen nach
Instrumenten also wenn es in Wolken
Fliege oder auch wenn ihr normal nach
Sicht Flieger die jeweiligen
Leistungsparameter Leistungsdaten und
sonstige Informationen die ich für die
Navigation brauche
beim Multifunktionsdisplay in der Mitte
das ist sehr sehr mannigfaltig was ich
mir hier in diesem Gerät anschauen kann
das wichtigste ist natürlich beim
Hubschrauber und die Turbinen zu
betreiben und anzulassen weil wir da mal
alle Triebwerks Parameter die für den
Piloten wichtig sind verschiedenste
Temperaturen verschiedenste Drücker von
den
Hydrauliksystemen und von den
Triebwerken ganz ganz verschiedene und
verschiedenartigste Informationen die
wir hier auf dem MFD geboten werden ich
kann dieses MFDs abgekürzt heißt das
Multifunktionsdisplay hier auf diesem
Knöpfen bedienen aber ich kann das mal
die Multifunktionsdisplay auch über den
seitlich Stick bedienen und ich kann im
Endeffekt wir mir verschiedenste Seiten
aufrufen die ich gerade für den
jeweiligen Flug brauche ich kann mir wie
hier die Systeme von Triebwerk und
Hydraulik und ähnlichen Systemen
anschauen ich kann hier auf die nächste
Seite gehen dass wir jetzt genauer die
Triebwerke und auch den jeweiligen
Füllstand der bedankung in den Tanks
dann kann ich weiterschütten komme ich
zu den elektronischen
Features in diesen Hubschrauber welche
verschiedene Bussysteme gerade im
Betrieb sind oder nicht dann kann er
weiter drücken zu den Hydrauliksystemen
kann das ganze Hydrauliksystem
überwachen mit drücken und jeweiligen
Temperaturen das Autopiloten
Kontrollsystem die Steuerungssystem und
verschiedenartigste Sachen kann ich mir
in diesem möglichen funktionsdisplay
aufrufen anschauen und im Flug auch
überwachen ich komme auch die Navigation
auf diese Multifunktionsdisplay hören
dann habe ich hier eine Karte wo ich im
Endeffekt beim Sichtflug jetzt mir
anschauen kann wo ich mich gerade
befinde
ich kann auch jetzt die Sicht nach unten
steuern das heißt ich habe hier Kameras
im Hubschrauber damit ich beim Außenlast
fliegen beim Waldbrand löschen bei der
Bergung mit der Winde beim mit dem
Hubschrauber nach unten schauen kann da
habe ich zwei Kameras drinnen ich habe
die cargocam die mir gerade nach unten
zeigt was ich gerade aufnehmen soll oder
Bergen soll und ich habe im Endeffekt
die Möglichkeit einer Kamera die nach
hinten sieht damit ich die jeweilige
eventuelle Hindernisse beim Absetzen des
Hubschraubers damit die nicht den
Hubschrauber unten beschädigen
ja so ist das Multifunktionsdisplay
aufgebaut und in diesem Bereich in der
Mitte habe ich wirklich sehr sehr viele
Möglichkeiten mir Informationen
darstellen zu lassen dann haben wir im
Endeffekt nur zwei weitere Computer hier
für jeden Piloten eines diese Geräte
können beide das gleiche das heißt hier
ist ganz geballt alles in von diesen
Hubschrauber aus steuerbar von
Frequenzen begonnen über das
Elektroniksystem über das
Fuel System das Hydrauliksystem dass ich
von hier aus nicht nur
beobachten kann wird oben sondern ich
kann es von hier aus auch Steuern
verschiedenste Sicherungen
Flugpläne und
Einstellmöglichkeiten für die Navigation
in diesem Gerät drinnen
im Endeffekt hier geht es ums Triebwerk
ist sehr sehr einfach gehalten der
Bereich ist eine sensieler Teil für uns
Piloten das ist nämlich der Bereich des
Autopiloten und der ist natürlich weil
wir ein Hubschrauber nicht nur
die Dimensionen haben die ein normaler
Flieger hat sondern wir können ja auch
schweben ist dieser Autopilot natürlich
auch dementsprechend komplex zu bedienen
und dann weiter zu schauen seine im
Endeffekt nur mehr Funkgeräte und
bedienen Panels wo ich mir einstellen
kann mit wem ich jetzt nach außen
sprechen soll oder mit wem ich sprechen
will beziehungsweise auch die
verschiedenen navigationsanlagen die ich
mir hier rein drehen kann um auch nicht
Instrumenten zu fliegen dann habe ich
noch die beiden steuerorgane den
Kollektiv wie heißt und hier der
seitlich dem Steuerrecht den
Hubschrauber in alle Richtungen und mit
dem Kollektiv dann nehme ich dem anziehe
wird der Hubschrauber nach oben oder
nach unten bewegt und wie wir auch
vorher gehört haben
ändert sich eurer Drehmoment mit jeder
Bewegung hier ändert sich der Drehmoment
und der heckrother muss dementsprechend
hinten arbeiten wie macht er das der
heckrotter wird vom Piloten bedient
durch diese Pedale das heißt der
drehmomentenausgleich funktioniert über
die Pedale und das der Hubschrauber
bleibt dann stabil der Hubschrauber hat
auch aufgrund dessen ist die letzte
Generation der Hubschrauber die
Möglichkeit alles von sich auszusteuern
das heißt ich kann im Flug und auch im
Schwebeflug im Endeffekt die Hände und
die Beine von den steuerorganen lassen
und kann den Hubschrauber dem
Autopiloten übergeben so nach dem
Einblick in cockpit schauen uns die
Gerät in Action an
[Musik]
so und wenn ihr Lust gehabt auf Version
coolen Gerät zu fliegen oder
mitzufliegen als Techniker dann
informiert euch auf karrierepunkt
bundesheer.at ich würde mir auf jeden
Fall freuen den einen oder anderen von
euch in meiner Staffel begrüßen zu
können
[Musik]